So to familiarize yourself with complexity theory and computability, here's our first quiz.
As in any Udacity course, the quizzes are here to help you see
if you have understood the content, and they do not count toward your final grade.
So our first quiz will be about familiarizing yourself
with the areas of computability and complexity theory.
Here I have 3 questions that you could ask in theoretical computer science.
So how fast can a computer find a way between 2 points on a map?
Can a program decide if another program is malware?
So, for example, a virus or trojan.
And how much memory is needed to sort a given database?
What I would like to know from you, for each of these 3 questions here,
is if that question would be studied in computability
or if that question would be studied in complexity theory.
Please make your selection for each of these questions.